hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast why we should clinically
classify genotypes not variants I am
Judy or Oracle at roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
leverage leading scientific social
networking website and provider a
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
we'd also like to acknowledge bc and en
media group for help with programming
and promotion of the events we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slides and go by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button at lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speakers dr. Nathaniel kherson Mason
Pearson is a senior director of
scientific engagement and public
outreach at the New York genome Center
where he and his colleagues those simple
engaging tools that compared one whole
human genome to the next in order to
cast new light on human health in
history today working with a talented
team of scientists and programmers he
helps researchers and consumers fit
through the billions of letters in each
human genome and understand which
important Spelling's make each person
unique if you would like more
information about our speaker please
click on his photo image in the top
right the planners for this event have
stated no relevant financial
relationships however dr. Kevin Davies
did disclose if he has a
scientific advisory board member serves
as one for pathway genomics and is on
the speaker's bureau for Harry Walker
incorporated and that neither constitute
a conflict of interest please note that
dr. Pearson has indicated he has no
relevant financial relationships
relative to this topic will now turn it
over to dr. Pearson for his presentation
thank you Judy and just confirming
everybody can hear me so welcome
everybody around the planet it's really
really great to be talking with folks
today grappling with precision medicine
hopefully turning medicine more precise
instead of vague medicine and absolutely
tickled and honored to be speaking today
among other speakers who have already
grown graced the the virtual podium here
who may have heard of and her today just
a wonderful event so depending on where
you are on the planet or if astronaut
scott kelly is tuning in from above the
planet you your weather may vary but
here in New York it's really very this
afternoon but I want us all regardless
of the weather on our part of a planet
to do a little thought experiment and
imagine going on a spring walk on a nice
day say with with your niece and niece
of yours who happens to be a young
naturalist and it's a long walk and your
knees gets tired from chasing rabbits
around very curious about the creatures
that you've seen and after the walk you
go to a drugstore to get or something to
drink a bottle of something that'll that
will quench the thirst of just having
chase rabbits all day and I want to talk
about about what you might encounter at
a drugstore what you might not encounter
a drugstore as it relates eventually did
to personalized medicine so imagine that
you go to a drugstore and you see a
bottle like this and it's got a pitch on
it and as it says drink me tells you how
much is there and it's got a little a
label that gets at some ingredients and
and this I think is a crux I want you to
pay attention to we're going to talk
today about genome labeling about truth
in what's in the bottle and what it
means to us in terms of health and how
we explain that to imagine that the
label on the bottle said contains carbon
hydrogen nitrogen and oxygen and each
one of those elements was
listed and and starred with a little a
little caveat that said may be hazardous
and i want to point this out that this
is not what we see when we go to a
drugstore today of course we see things
that are labeled differently but in
doing so I want to point out on through
this analogy that i'll get to that we're
doing this in genomics today we're doing
this the wrong way we're labeling things
wrong and today I'm going to talk about
how we can label them more precisely to
better understand what's going on and
actually make medicine more personalized
so imagine that instead of a bottle of a
liquid for quenching thirst we have a
bottle of genomic information a genome
from a person so 6.6 Giga bases played a
flagon of information to deal with murky
stuff inside in terms of what it may
contain and what it what may harm us
what may not and that's what we'd like
to understand is that label would that
we get back BSA a physician a patient a
family member of patient to pay or
whomever it may be whatever stakeholder
or we are in the system here imagine we
unscrolled what's inside we might find
some interesting content so this is
these are variants from my own genomics
that when I read my whole genome these
are some of the ones that stood up is
quite curious so there's a couple of
interesting carrier variants in here in
BLD in and 80s and there are some novel
nonsense ransom or not in some cases
quite rare innocence variants not always
novel but variants that cut short
proteins and that make me curious about
whether or not they may affect my health
in a particular way and the question is
how do we interpret the experience that
inevitably we find in any person's
genome so I want to liken this question
to that face by a previous naturalist
and of course you may have recognized
the naturalist chasing rabbits and
dating back to 150 years ago Alice
chasing a rabbit into Wonderland of
course one of the great characters in
that story asked about rare nonsense
about uncommon nonsense and said I
should like to have explained so the
mock Turtles question here uncommon
nonsense I should like to have it
explained rangoon well for me as often
what we're trying to do in interpret
given human genome today understand that
that rare variant that may look
intriguing to us functionally but we
don't quite know how to interpret it
so if we cast our time machine back to
that year 1865 of course and we had to
say a panel of 10 speakers many of the
famous ones would be dead white men
today Charles Dodgson the the writer of
Alice in Wonderland might be one of the
speakers there there might be Charles
Darwin who at that point was working I
think on the French translation of on
the origin of species having had sort of
like launched his great work into the
world and have its kind of pervade
science already nearby but but alas not
knowing Darwin we had Gregor Mendel
finishing up the last tally of a very
crucial crop of peas that was going to
introduce us into the basis of
systematically probing genetics and the
heritability of phenotypes and a
four-speaker whom we might not have
heard of now might be a guy named
ditional courtois and I want to
introduce him if you don't know who
ditional court why is he actually
figures quite prominently in the early
history of chemistry and I think this is
where I'm tickled that Kevin Davis
invited me because kevin has has
embarked on a new career that involves
in some ways something explained
chemistry to the world in addition to
genomics but if we cast back to that
year du schon Courtois brought us the
first helix it wasn't a double helix the
first he lives in chemistry and this was
a predecessor of the periodic table so
deshawne Courtois noticed that the
properties of elements varied in a
periodic way in a recurring way by their
molecular weight and he made this spiral
this helix model but called the telluric
helix to help us understand that
periodicity and this was a real
important forerunner of Mendeleev's
later periodic table so if we think back
to our understanding of chemistry at
that time let's do a little history
lesson here what do we know about
chemistry and health so back in 1865 we
knew about 56 elements being the
simplest stuff that we can easily
isolate on the planet ditional Courtois
figured prominently in cataloging those
noticing that they their their
properties varied in a periodic way by
weight and that those properties in turn
were key to understanding and
understanding the world itself this
composition and the composition of stuff
in it and eventually to the ways we want
to tinker with it so it's understanding
what is going to blow up in a chemistry
lab lab and what is
and what is going to hurt us and what
isn't in addition to elements we already
knew in addition to those 56 elements
and you might think of the 56 e CMG
jeans today but in addition to the
elements we also knew and classified
another concept which were molecules and
molecules specifically be in
combinations of one or more elements in
particular amounts and Link
configurations and think about that for
a moment because we're going to see a
direct analogy to where we are in
genomics importantly of course molecules
do much more than the sum of their
constituent elements so the elements may
have particular various properties
carbon hydrogen nitrogen and oxygen but
their combination in a molecule in
particular amounts and linkages yield
very different properties depending what
those amounts and linkages are and
they're more than just the sums of you
know the stoichiometry of that element
some of them in fact we are we had
already figured out their effects on
health so the first toxicological report
of the attributing sort of toxicology
solving a murder traced it to nicotine
poisoning so we already knew that
nicotine was was part of some bad stuff
for us at the time and so we understood
something about the structure of some
molecules then without benzene structure
result by early in 1850s and about their
health effects on us as distinct from
those of the elements that made them up
and importantly when you learned about
these things you learned about them in
grade school so they were fundamental to
every basic education pretty much around
the planet today these two very distinct
kinds of concepts and and importantly
the complexity of molecules over that of
the simplicity of elements so if we
think about that complexity let's take a
very simple chemical formula c 10 h 14
oh and look at some of the molecules
that that have that formula and their
various properties and some of them
figure and famous saw rock songs or as a
substitute something might get might
have gotten in the 60s have you bought
have you bought your your bag from the
wrong dealer you might get oregano
instead so oil of oregano fits that
parsley sage rosemary and thyme so
rosemary oil also is the same formula
time oil is a different conformation of
the same oil they all smell slightly
different from each other and then you
might be
donovan song saffron it's wonderful
smell is a very different conformation
of the same stoichiometry pennyroyal
moving along to Nirvana and the 90s is
has some health effects beyond just
smelling good it's a mint but it's been
used for a long time as folk medicine to
induce support abortions and it's
actually unclear how well this works we
might think of other other molecules of
the same formula like this one which is
actually from a headache tree called the
headache tree and you do not want to
injustice when it actually will make you
puke so the properties of all these vary
greatly and some of them you're even
used outside of nice smelling perfumes
but for things like controlling pests so
this is a beetle pheromone that fits the
same stoichiometric with very different
properties the other and some of them we
even get to complexities like mirror
images so here are two enantiomers with
this same formula the what one chirality
one handedness of the molecule smells
like spearmint the other exact same
formula just a mirror image just a foot
molecule ah smells like caraway so I
think a cool example of how a given
molecule is more than the sum of just
its its constitutive elements in terms
of its structure matters and the
linkages among those elements matter so
how we don't track the chemistry of
health so have knowing that molecules
matter and kelton that they they matter
for labeling for example when we go to
the drugstore we don't expect pharmacist
to keep the on the counter a periodic
table where they markup nitrogen with
some some background information so I
know you know it's harmless it's benign
in in its free form but if you combine
it with a gas and bond it with 2 o's
together becomes caustic as a caustic
gas or if you make it in with a triple
bond to a nitrogen turning it into
cyanide it turns acutely toxic over its
neurotoxic in some Alkaline combinations
with ch and Oh funny about Lloyd drugs
etc have that particular composition
this is not how we track the chemistry
helped through like a heavily marked up
periodic table of elements so we'd end
up with something that looks like this
back to your rock and roll the periodic
table on on a Rolling Stones album this
is not how it's done
pharmacy today rather a pharmacist or a
pharmacologist and understanding what's
inside the bottle of how it may affect
you it's going to go to a database of
information about about molecules not
about elements themselves so we might
track the cognitive the properties of a
molecule like methamphetamine in terms
of health in a database that's dedicated
to that building on maybe you saw these
in med school with your position of the
old bio Stein german-language catalogue
of organic chemistry but more modern
versions like pubchem that now catalog
business knowledge systematically
outside of the concept of element but in
that of compound and you might think of
the label in question so if we labeled a
nice healthy food like a banana this way
we might actually label it buy it buy
them up the molecules it contains and
here's great example of what we see as
we labeled something we consider natural
by contrast how are we tracking the
genomic health so when we open up that
genome bottle and try to drink from it
and get some insight how are we
understanding what's inside first
conventionally we're tracking a very
simple very simple concept that is
variance so variance being the simplest
way that two chromosomes can hair ibly
differ so you can imagine a simple
spelling change there often just a
single base substitution they could be
more a bit more complex from that that
we get into long variances in dells
transpositions inversions etc but
basically variants are the atomic way of
that chromosomes can differ from each
other paratively importantly they make
me match or mismatch an arbitrary
reference genome today so we can talk
about that a bit in questions if we want
to it's an important point that
reference genome bring some biases to
the table that we could discuss item and
it is really important to understand
right so the way their actual Spelling's
in terms of faith composition so that
see versus that T or that that inversion
or that transposition tell us a lot
about the history of the chromosomes
involved so how they've evolved in turn
the history of the population of
organisms that they belong to so us how
big the population has been who has
migrated with whom and who
stuck to them over time and in turn
about physiology so not just mutation
processes and an evolutionary history
but what the correlates of those may say
something about about physiology as well
so we see nonsense variant attentive for
example cut cut protein short and in
doing so be more important than missense
variants that matters and we should
track that knowledge however tying
individual variants to help typically
presumes that those variants have in
simple strong and independent effects
and if you think about this this is a
habit that traces back to our early
efforts really you know yeoman efforts
in early clinical genetics where we
could only read a few genes at a time
typically in a few people of time it was
so expensive and so we start with the
sickest people first and look at them we
ended up with a pertinent biases and we
ended up with problems later when we
look at more people many of them who are
healthy and started to see that the
variance we presume were harmful and
strongly so often turned out to be
impenetrable week or they they
disappeared on on broader statistical
survey and of course now with the boon
of fast cheap sequencing we can we can
read many many more genomes more
comprehensively we can start we're
starting to grapple with this problem
love and penetrance much more so we want
to make genomes not just diagnostically
useful for people who are urgently sick
today or for a tumor but prognostically
useful so that we know what will happen
with somebody born with a particular of
that bottle that's that genome bottle so
I'm going to argue today that we should
instead be clinically classifying and
reporting genotypes not variants
themselves and if and so we'll go
through what this means but if if you
have no time this is the gist of the
talk so you know my main argument here
and the rest will be commentary and I'll
explain why we should do so when in
genotype being a combination of one or
more variants at one or more sites on
one or more chromosome copies so it
could start as simply as a single site
and you could have a genotype that was c
/ v two copies of see CT heterozygote or
two
copies of T that would be a genotype and
it elastically can can grow to include
more sites on that chromosome of course
but also sites on other chromosome so
it's a very elastic concept that takes
into account something very simple today
a single site but also multiple sites as
our knowledge grows the variance
involved can importantly in a genotype
as in a molecule they can interact with
each other non-additive we're going to
show some examples of that importantly
because when I say now inevitably I mean
that the genotypes qualities its
properties will be more than the sum of
its constitutive variants and
importantly if we start to do this if we
start to actually classify them and
clinically report genotypes rather than
variants I'm arguing that this much more
it puts us in a much more robust track
to track our are growing insights into
the genomic basis of health along with
other factors that matter of health that
starts with today's fairly simple single
genome single site in a genome knowledge
single variant focused knowledge but
grows elastically over time as we
sequence and look at more people over
time and not and and notice that the
correlates between particular genotypes
and particular phenotypes over time
crucially I want to make one point here
which is that this is not a new insight
Mendel from the very start actually
understood this that we that we need to
be reporting genotypes and what we'll
get to that in a moment so the analogy
it does extend and I want to make it
here so if you think of variances being
roughly analogous to elements the sort
of simple atomic way in which things
vary in the domain were looking at you
can imagine that very rare at what we
call a rare penetrance variant is a bit
like a really rare and harmful element
so like something like polonium where it
doesn't really matter if you're looking
at polonium chloride or for Liam Brona
bromide any salt of polonium it's going
to be bad for you you don't want to eat
it and likewise there are plenty of
variants out there that regardless of
the genomic background regardless how
complex is the rest of that person's
phenotype is they are going to harm that
person in some way and those were the
ones that we discovered early on in
clinical genomics that have turned out
to be the most robust findings
from from early clinical genetics and
I'm arguing here that has biased towards
this sort of myopic view of classifying
and reporting variants thinking that it
was always going to be so simple and
it's not so simple and we'll get two
examples but if we extend the analogy
you could think of reference variants
the ones that we often omit from a
report as being something like the
hydrogen that we might omit from a
chemical formula because it's given the
hydrogen bonds to carbon so that sort of
often just left out for simplicity in
fur and for contactless there are some
variants that recur in the world and
tumors for example that that happens
that by new mutation in parallel over
and over again and we can start to look
for and they often are important in
health those you might think of
something like a radionuclide that is
often made and new from from another
Mari another element in the world as it
decays and likewise if we think then of
genotypes is being analogous to
molecules that is combinations that one
or more of the atomic units in
particular amounts and linkages then you
can imagine asking about a partial gene
type so part of a molecule with my
column moiety and if it does something
important we might call that a
functional group hydroxyl group etc we
will likely start to discover partial
genotypes that say enough on their own
to be interpreted regardless of the
broader context they're part of and the
analogy can extend further so if you
think about the copy you know how many
copies of a given variant are in the
genome that's something like the
stoichiometry of how many copies of an
element are in a compound or given atom
are in that compound if you think about
how genotypes are passed on together
that's something like the way that that
that elements are bonded together either
in a strongly linked way in a covalent
wedding or in a loser way there in the
same person and they might get
transmitted together they might not
which you can think of as a bit like an
ionic bond as as generations go by and
then there's even some kind of little
twist to it so you could remember that
example of the spearmint and the carewe
that are mirror image molecules there
are of course genotypes that that have
very different effects
whether or not you get them from one
parent or another so they're the same
genotype but epigenetically they're
imprinted with distinct effect so you
might think they're of probability and
uncommon syndrome tracing to two extra
copies of chromosome 15 or parts of it
and it matters very much whether you get
that extra copy from mom or from death
finally Howard genotypes made or their
variants come together sorry elements
come together through reaction and of
course there's a replication process
where that brings new new variants
together recombination does that it as
we reproduce so there's an extended
analogy here where Mendel does mean
Mendeleev Anna and I want to make this
the crux of our discussion today as I
noted Mendel got this from the very
start of genomics he he saw this
complexity so if you recall back to his
main experiments he was looking at tea
plants and my name is asking who say
crossing purple flowered and and white
flowered pea plants and he might have
expected or Darwin might have expected
at this time blending so that the
offspring would be safe pink or lavender
flower that's of course not what he got
so what he found was that the offspring
that the kids of these D plants remain
either purple flower to white flowers
and from the clever mass that he did he
deduced that this trace to effectively a
genotype and importantly a non-additive
genotype so were if inheritance in
Mendel's world were additives then the
heterozygote blooms would have been pink
instead they are purple because of the
dominance of the the big are illegal but
a purple allele over the little R allele
and that dominant turned out to be so
widespread and so easily found in
genomics that we've actually forgotten
that it's just not it's not an additive
genomic interaction at the genotype
level we gave it a special name and
we've tracked it in our clinical
databases as dominant versus recessive
forms of disease and in some cases we
get tripped up we're looking for one and
we find the other in a particular
patient but but we tend tend to track
this as sort of like a flag as an add-on
in how we report variants rather than is
something that could be more neatly
subsumed into a broader understanding of
non added genotype
cortina there are other examples of
non-additive ax t that we've known about
for a long time so another might be sex
sex chromosome genotype dependence and
this is one that's sort of so obvious
that we've forgotten that it actually is
a genomic interaction and non-additive
one so if you're if you are a position
and you get a report for somebody with a
particular brca1 or 2 variants that look
scary from the literature it matters
very much whether or not that person has
an X X genotype or XY now of course
anybody can get breast cancer so men get
breast cancer too nonetheless the risks
are much higher on an xx genomic
background the next Y genomic background
in that particular case and again this
is one that's sort of so obvious we've
often forgot about it that it does
reflect am NOT an additive genomic
interaction that we already understand
there are other examples that we've that
we've sort of run across and started to
grapple with and we've often sort of
swept them under their own special
category rugs so mitochondrial variation
because we only get one copy of our
mitochondrial genome from one parent and
it is recombinant is that genome doesn't
recombine but rather accumulates
variation over time in a haplotype
setting we tend to think of the the
effect of haplotypes in mitochondrial
variation where we've gathered with that
before we have elsewhere in our genomes
and there are a few other there are a
few other places where we have
long-standing kappa type diversity that
stable thanks to various processes
evolutionarily such as HLA and
immunoglobulins Oh slow sigh and kilo
studies other hypervariable and you know
elephant parks our genomes as well as
long kappa types that are relevant to
drug response such as the the enzymes
that encode many live in technically
liver enzymes for detoxifying drugs
cyp450 teams those we've started to
record our functional knowledge
typically not at the single simple
variant level but often at the haplotype
level we've started to see that this
stuff is a bit more complex than
reporting a simple single variants now
let's talk about some other emerging
insights into non activity that have not
been understood for so long but but will
shine the light on where this will go is
we look at more
more people's genomes and want to make
our understanding of their long-term
health arc more precise so we can
started within the same gene we've
understood compounds het better ed ology
for a while we often when we're asleep
looking at a sick child and what's
making her sick we may find that that
that does a case of disease traces two
distinct variants in the same gene that
would each nominally be recessive so
normally you need two copies to get sick
but effectively they turn each other
dominant and that's what we call
compound hat etiology there are many
examples in the literature many of us
have started to report those if we're
clinical geneticists for empowered
patient families we may have to consider
that possibility in looking at what's
making a child sick in the family there
are also emerging new examples where
what's what what's really interesting is
that is that the genotype is actually
the rare genotype is actually associated
not with disease but with helps so this
is a great example from the prion
protein so the gene that encodes the
gram protein is PRP one I encourage you
to look at this this particular art
where it this is a really really cool
example because there is a dimorphism
there's a simple to beta one base
substitution in PRP in the 129 codon
where some some copies of that gene
encoding a thymine there and some copies
in quote a valine actually both of those
variants might get called pathogenic
because it turns out oddly that
homozygotes are more they tend to get
pre on that they are less susceptible to
prion disease than then heterozygotes so
if you have it if you have two copies of
an M there you are you I'm sorry I said
that wrong so either if you have two
copies of an M or if you have two copies
of a fee you can you are susceptible to
prion disease whereas if heads are less
susceptible so but either either variant
there can effectively be called harmful
with respect to pre on susceptibility
nonetheless in a study of folks from New
Guinea where
people have eaten brain tissue for a
long time including some people there it
was an intriguing new variant sound very
nearby in that gene it actually appears
to block prion disease completely so at
their 127 codon in that gene if you have
this particular rare variant you appear
to be so far immune to prion disease
utterly immune regardless of what
genotype you have nearby it at codon 129
so this would be a great example of
emerging insights from looking at many
people in the world including previously
understudying people populations on the
planet of finding rare variations that
makes a rare genotype that is actually
helps that drives health rather than
disease so further examples not just
within the same gene but across gene so
this is a great example of so-called die
genic ideology where again we have
variants that would normally be called
recessive so a variant and RDS or in ROM
one you normally need two copies of
either one to get our retinitis
pigmentosa this isn't us you can look at
this old paper it's fairly well known
now but effectively they turn each other
domina this is like compound head across
genes where if you happen to get both
you tend to get RP and it's bad news but
this is a non additive and interaction
across genes and likewise we can flip
that and think about we're very sorry
where and gene type associated health
across genes as well so a recent study a
population scale in iceland found
intriguing an intriguing new variants in
a PP that as part of any any genes head
background the folks about that
including apoe4 basically buffers the
the expected pathogenic effect of a
belief or so i plead for photo carry
people who carry an a blade for allele
tend to if there has they tend to have a
modestly higher incidence of alzheimer's
disease if they are homozygous for that
that particular variant attendant have
much higher but if they carry this
particular rare variant in a pee-pee in
addition that genotype together is a
fairly
if there's no difference it's a fairly
low risk for Alzheimer's disease
regardless so again we have we need to
be looking at the person genotype as a
whole in terms of what's already known
about it to understand their outlook for
ad in this case not just as a single
site in a Bowie that we would typically
look at and this gets even work here
when we come to the ATM DS 5016 of
themselves so famously of course a CMD
took a look at what we already know
about the about the genetic basis of
importance adult onset diseases that we
could do something about and they said
what genes weird what genes we know most
about their roles in adult onset disease
where there's some screening or
prevention and or treatment option
available to help someone and they made
a list of 56 teens it's a really great
first start at knowing what kinds of
things we would like to report
especially as incidental findings from
looking at someone's genome one of the
genes are actually two of the genes on
that list rms h1 and that's our mlh1
msh2 both of those teams are strongly
implicated in colorectal cancer so in
lynch syndrome and other colorectal
cancers nonetheless this this study was
a really important one that I'd point
you to showing how little we yet
understand about the long-term risk of
stop that disease even from this best
understood of genes so the study looked
at about a couple hundred families in
which eat own each family there was a
pathogenic variant a nominally by a
Clinton like you know clinvar annotated
pathogenic variants segregating that
family and they looked at whether or not
folks who had a copy of that Barry
actually got colorectal cancer by a
particular age I think they were looking
at men and the families by getting
cancer by 870 they found in about a
sixth of the families that nine of 10
men are more would get cancer colorectal
cancer by 70 so that's that's
effectively what we want is we don't
want people to get cancer of course but
we want to be able to predict from a
single variant that they that they
likely will and then hopefully do
something about it however the silvering
flip side is that we found
another six the families that the
lifetime risk appeared to be less than
ten percent so these are the same
variance different families different
genomic backgrounds different life
styles etc there are other interactions
that play here that are going to help
explain hopefully over time why we yet
know so little even for this you know
well understood a CMV 56 listed genes
why we understand so little about
whether or not someone will or won't get
colorectal cancer given a particular
bearing and hopefully as we get more and
more big data from some populations
including genomic data but also the
ancillary data that goes with it and
track people over time we can start to
understand some of those interactions
and some of them made sure not to be
genetic and likely in some cases non
additives the same way we've seen before
so what I'm arguing today is that all of
us together need to get our our health
infrastructure our health informatics
infrastructure in particular ready to
record and convey that knowledge as it
emerges from the data that we now have
at hand and coming and why this matters
of course for healthcare is why we're
here today we want to sharpen healthcare
to make it more precise for for us for
our families for our patients for
everyone in our lives there on the
planet and importantly that starts with
the job of caregivers themselves so
making life life easier for for a
caregiver is one key way in which the
innovations that we propose can be taken
up so currently let's let's take a look
at what you know and by the way we you
know a doctor doesn't want a flagon of
insight from a genome they want a little
espresso so they want to be able to sit
this espresso on a report know what to
do in act on it and we'd like to help
them do that so how do we streamline the
job of a doctor with genotypes versus
variants well let's take a look at a
hypothetical genome today and it might
be reported back this is a particularly
unlucky looking one so this person might
have five particular variants called as
pathogenic which would be kind of scary
typically most of us would have probably
zero to two such variants call but this
is a jackpot that gets five and so this
is a scary list to go through for the
patient but also
the caregiver who's trying to walk
through and understand what if anything
can be done how to explain these
findings to a patient's so the
particular variants in question might be
implicated in breast cancer and long QT
syndrome in LVL community in sort of
blood lipids in amelia's and beta
thalassemia for example so if we bring
into a single site genotype knowledge
rather than just reporting these
variants the picture changes a fair bit
so now we're looking at the genotypes of
this person not just the variants that
got flagged and work and work clinically
classifying those genotypes so we're no
longer have five red ones at five
pathogenic but rather we have three
genotypes that it's a simple view would
still be deemed pathogenic and two it
might be deemed instead we might call it
a family risk and let me thoughts walk
through those so here we were still
heterozygous for this variant in an
abusive we are see aging this looks
scary in a gene implicated in long QT
and it wasn't implicated in high low
density lipoprotein none but the the
genotypes for cinematic anemia that says
that's the recess genotype which is a
really cool one that's under dominant
plus it's uh it's the rare case in human
genetics where heterozygotes are at a
disadvantage and we could go through
that offline it's a really cool little
story but if you're homozygous it's more
of a family risk question and likewise
the beta thalassemia risk is if you're
heterozygous it's more of a family risk
question for family members who might be
homozygous for that same variant so now
we've made the report a bit more precise
in terms of how we caught the fyke
pathogenic for the person versus for
family risk and we made it a bit easier
I think for the doctor to go through the
findings and know what's most important
to talk about first now if we extend
further beyond these single sites to
incorporate what we already know so
these are already informative genotypes
across multiple sites in this person's
genome we can get even sharper and
actually it turns out that all of these
genotypes basically collapsed to being
just family risks there is nothing
pathogenic that nothing pathogenic ly
alarming among the five listed here for
the person at hand but rather they might
forum screening for other family members
so for example they might be mailed it
might have a XY genotypes that will
likely buffers that really strongly
affected a strong effect expected for
the BRCA variant nonetheless it might
mean that they should have tell other
members of their family eventually a
year now or later that they might want
to be screened for that variant as well
as they have an xx background in
particular and likewise based on the
papers that we already know about we
could collapse all of these two similar
kinds of families screening questions
but at the genotype level we might find
something new as well so here is the
case of a genotype across multiple sites
in two different genes on two different
chromosomes in this person none of which
none of the variance in question here
would on their own be called pathogenic
but together they convert a quite strong
risk for ankylosing spondylitis but
based on what's known about the
interaction between one of the HLA genes
on chromosome 6 energyne called erap one
and so none of these the constituent
variants of this genotype would rise to
the in clinvar to being called
pathogenic but the combination would be
clearly so so I would argue that this is
this is quite alarming in terms of the
if you look at the papers and this
person's risk for developing AFS over
time so the demon that can help us both
sets all cookies and make the doctor's
job a bit easier for explaining about
family screening versus alarmingly
having to go through five you know fire
alarms for that person but it can also
clue us into new findings from that
person that we said we wouldn't have
seen if we were only reporting back
single variants but instead we were
looking what we already know about
genotypes there are some clever twists
and some tough twists to this and I want
to I want to acknowledge those and we're
going to have to grapple with them going
forward so we've looked at a lot of
people genomes now we find that that
there are tons of the variants out there
so we already know about many dozens of
millions of single simple variance among
people's genomes and it turns out that
given how fast the human population has
grown recently the more people we
sequence we can expect to continue to
find our rare variants in abundance so
variants that are there
individually rare but collectively very
common and just rights among us likewise
if you think about how all those
millions of variance to be combined it's
boggling right so Gina there are many
more possible genotypes yes and variants
they can be combined in almost infinite
possible combinations and so we we need
infrastructure for being able to track
what we know about those now the lucky
thing is here that we don't have to
track we don't have to have an entry in
our database for every genotype that's
possible we only have to track the ones
that we already know or informative in
some way and that list will grow much
more slowly than the exponential
possibilities so we only need to track
and formative genotypes and in
particular clinically informative ones
as they slowly a true beyond the single
site knowledge we have now but I'm
arguing that by converting to our
computing systems now to track genotypes
this way including with ambiguity so so
knowing that for example that this
genotype this part of this unit head
could be either had or homozygous but it
has to be hit one or the other so we
need ambiguity coach built into how we
encode genotypes even doing so will only
roughly double our database size today
versus if you take a database like
Clinton or if our sorry clinvar which is
actually so quite small it's on the
order of a few dozen thousand variants
that are clinically classified if we
classify genotypes instead we would
barely double that size we still when we
have dozens of thousands of genotypes to
keep track up that would be clinically
classifiable today and that would grow
slowly as we look at more people over
time Jesus eyes can overlap each other
so they can fully assist me the one
genotype consume another completely or
they can partially overlap so we need
structured syntax and look at what if
our tissues would call schema database
schema that is well thought out ways of
encoding the data in rows and columns
and with keys and values kept so I oh so
crucial IDs it's high one table to
another then let us track that overlap
and smart ways so that we know when we
know something about a genotype that
overlaps another over weekend if we can
know whether whether or not to
functionally that the second genotype
that may be newly discovered made
in some ways similar to the other one
that's a bit like knowing whether a
newly synthesized molecule is going to
act like one that it shares some
moieties with for example this is
completely tractable and of course much
more so now that database science has
become quite a rigorous and and a well
structured method in its own right and
so we have good computational methods
for doing this in other domains and we
can do this I think much better and so
it so now that we could tracking it on
paper in the past now the other twist
here that's that makes looking at
genotypes from their health effects top
is that genotype you know i doona time
is going to be found in no more people
than any of its constitutive variants so
they attended each gene types going to
tend to be rarer than even the rarest
variants within it and this makes
detecting association statistically hard
and we already faced this with single
variants that in a variant needs maybe
in too few people in the world
significantly associate with with
disease even if it's only mountain and
sick people there may be just too few of
them on the planet to know whether
that's significant or not and there of
course we have to turn as as you know
missus to things like rare variant
burden tests other kinds of rare variant
association test that pool variants
together to have statistical questions
and we've got some two methods for doing
that here and we have we have to adapt
those methods for looking at genotypes
as well importantly we only come to
track than 128 with you know once we
have evidence for the given view size
does matter health we only need to track
it again when it becomes clinically
informative across people and the other
the other twist and wrinkle that arises
because variants are sorry team tests
are found each and few people is that
they are more informative about the
identity of that person now I would
argue here that that privacy worries
presumes that that genome data are going
to be widespread that we will be in a
world soon where we're substituting for
stuff used in genome data and so be
possible to know that given someone in
the genome database and a genome that
within a database and had a particular
gene type we have to have other
information about the person who carry
in the world north in order to be able
to match them together so we may come to
that point and we'll have to deal with
that we do but that and that maybe there
will be trade-offs there in terms of the
clinical utility of this data across
labs and helping patients versus the
privacy concerns of each of those of the
people who make karaoke and finally
variants of course our space no matter
so we still need a periodic table we
haven't jettisoned the periodic table
just because we have pubchem it still
matters to catalogue what we know about
variants they still tell us about about
mutation processes in the past about
about population history and we still
need to fly them within genotypes if we
as we've noted where they might be
shared in the different genotypes in
somebody else in the family where it
matters more so it's on an xx background
versus X Y etcetera in the simple case
but in the case is to come where we
learn more about other kinds of
interactions we will need to know that
your ear sibling is much more likely to
carry one of your rare variants than
your first cousin and yet more likely
you know than yours and your second door
or cousin or or a distant stranger the
take homes that I want to us to you know
to think about today and hoping you guys
will okay call when we talk about in
questions include that as I'm basically
are going to say that we need to start
classifying clinically informative
genotypes now and then doing so will
help basically make healthcare more
robust make our infrastructure more
robust for its narrow use today where we
even if we use genomes today to diagnose
right we have cells growing too fast to
wait so a sick child growing too fast to
wait for sequencing to get cheaper or
four for knowledge to grow or we have a
tumor growing too fast for sequencing to
get cheaper or for knowledge to grow we
want to look at the genome of that tumor
or of that sick child today and know if
there's any foothold into helping
diagnose and treat something urgent the
longer term broad use of genomes that we
all aspire to in it that you know the
precision medicine efforts are built
around he used to make genomes
prognostically useful not just urgently
diagnostically useful but useful looking
ahead from room to old age as a part of
long-term pipe health management and
that involves the much more murky
question of how someone's health is
going to slowly evolve over time not
necessarily be already understood and to
be diagnosed yet and I'm arguing here
that because genotypes matter in that
question of impenetrable of the crystal
ball of whether a given variant is going
to make someone sick that classifying
and reporting now getting people used to
working with genotypes is going to make
that much easier for our whole
healthcare system when it does become
possible and importantly the key is to
ease caregiver jobs and this takes me
back to a great essay by I think Atul
Gawande wrote a New Yorker article about
three years ago about the uptake of two
revolutionary technologies in the
eighteen hundreds so one was
hand-washing and one was surgical
anesthetics and and anesthesia they were
both events I think in the 19th century
and one of them was taken up by surgeons
overnight and one of them took 30 years
not to take up and of course anesthesia
was the one that was taken up right away
and hand Washington was the one that
took a long time and go on days he are
used that the reason was that that one
of the both of the maids life great for
patients they both extended millions of
lives over time but only one of the maid
doctors wives easier right anesthesia
turn surgery from what what was
basically a carefully orchestrated
attack on a patient with a lot of
screaming and holding people down and
blood and tears to one that was much
more the serene precise art that we
think of this surgery today where
there's music playing in the operating
theatre etc hand-washing by contrast
made made life tedious it meant you had
to be very careful about what you did
and keep track of even more procedures
than you otherwise have to it in the
operating room and so here I'm arguing
that that classifying genotypes would
actually make doctor's lives easier we
keep the report shorter and more precise
more clear than what they need to
explain to a patient less full of the
false alarm you know 55
red alarm variances but rather just a
few that might a few have findings that
might matter for that patients and
importantly all this in the long run can
help lengthen lives by conveying
insights about people's health going
forward more sharply and this is what
you know the essence of precision
medicine and I argue that we should
switch now so rather than waiting rather
than wringing your hands and say well of
course you know that this sounds great
we should we should be talking about
genotypes but my lab can wait because we
have a database right now you know
variants that it's going to be hard to
switch over it's only going to get
harder so we do our databases right now
are fairly small and they're fairly
young still in terms of the computing
that we put into them they're going to
grow over time and they're going to get
more deeply embedded in many of the
systems that we as various stakeholders
and healthcare that we run and we should
switch now to genomically to start
genotype tracking in our computational
infrastructure before that variant
centrism really really embeds itself
it'll in everything that we do it has it
sort of tendrils throughout our whole
our whole system so what can you do
depending on who you are what kind of
stakeholder you are if you're an
implementation if your job is to help
structure data and get it ready for
other for scientists and clinicians to
look at later structure your data now
for multi-site genotypes build it so
that you can accommodate that elastic
concept that starts with a single site
now but could accommodate in sites
across multiple sites on a chromosome or
even on different chromosomes over time
and we can talk offline about how that
helps today even for for quality control
questions that are crucial in today's
short range genome data if by contrast
your genomic this I intezar if you
happen to be someone who's been
sequenced already shared whole genome
not just flattened allele frequency
tables of single variants that will help
today to boost power of studies it will
help us understand whether or not
genotypes a particular genotypes
actually correlate with with disease
more sharply than individual variants
may and so you know think you think in
gmail sync and whole genomes and
shareholdings if you can if you have
that chance as a scientist and if you
happen to have in sequence share your
genome
it's a great thing to do on behalf of
science if you're someone that works at
the bench so not just in a dry lab but
actually at a wet lab what people what
you can do is help us understand the
functional effects of game types but
actually asking them in parallel and
this gets one of the challenges we saw
earlier that if a genotype is really
rare in the world it may be impossible
to know statistically how it affects
health but we have emerging ways through
crisper and other highly parallelizable
technologies in the lab to directly ask
that functionally and so you could ask
about you could actually imagine not
just tweaking the genomes of a cell line
to have a single variance but actually
tweaking them to have a slightly more
complex genotype that was found in the
given tation and asking whether or not
under conditions that approximate those
you know that we think drive disease in
a person that the cells in that dish act
in some way that reflects reality ology
or whether we're on the wrong leaf if
you're a clinical geneticist if you're
interpreting the findings that come from
genomes today think and report gene
types so again it's not that much more
complex to make that that's that final
report to clinicians specify that c /
teeth rather than just the teeth or
specify the c / t + XX get folks used to
looking at that because it becomes
second nature and they won't think twice
they will understand if they need to the
basis of your findings more clearly in
the basis of the recommendations that
you pass on in clinical reports about
about patients and about other folks
intimately sequence in their families so
maybe the parents who have internal
findings as well and importantly if you
are that caregiver if you're a doctor if
you're a nurse practitioner if you're
patient think in genotypes and request
stuff so if your clinical geneticist is
not reporting unit types and it's in
that sense leaving more ambiguity in
terms of how do I report this a set of
of three red flags are you know are they
all red flags for the person in hand or
is anything else is something else known
in the literature that would clarify
which of these matter most to talk about
now with the patient versus to help
understand family screening for asked
for that so request genotypes in your
reports yet get your clinical geneticist
partner used to thinking that way as
well and I'm arguing here that if all of
us change our thinking a little bit this
way sir and insert you know hark back to
what Mendel already got and to where big
data will take us we can we can change
the culture of how clinical findings are
reported from our genomes to be more
focused and ready for the complexity
that will emerge over time as genotypes
of 23 and perhaps even four or five
sites eventually become informative over
the course of our lifetimes so thank you
so much for listening to the polemic
today and I'd love to talk with you guys
about questions that emerged on your
minds now well thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our I
intellij submit questions you can submit
questions like typing them in the Q&A
box which can be found like clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is the view ask feast
eccentric alike notation does not even
indicate the gloucestershire questions
to comment what do you want to comment
on that yeah and I think it's classic so
in an office of view you know this
particular variant is one of those that
workers in many different tumors and
we'd like to understand it especially
given that many cancers are already
understood as as multi-hit diseases
especially in how they respond to
treatment and there are some variants
that are that that appear to buffer the
effects of other variants in a tumor or
buffer the responses or exacerbate the
responses in non-additive ways so the
great point here when we get to mer
findings on a tumor report we've often
see something like yes it might even
take something as simple as this tumor
is beer a positive leaving info mini
anything about the genotype is Olivia
you know it's a variant in question let
alone the genotype of that site zygosity
does matter and zygosity matters you in
even more complex ways and tumors
because they actually accumulate copy
number variation so a tumor could start
out as you know heterozygous for v600e
it could get a second copy of the be to
get a second
maybeee it could lose a copy of the B
and become effectively hemizygous for
that and all that may matter and how it
responds to treatment over time we need
to know about that so oncologist
pathologist likewise need to start
thinking in genotype terms here perhaps
even more pressingly because we
understand the multi multi-hit nature of
tumor etiology and the role of sy
gossipy and a venue party in tumors
themselves their boats bahama DJ have
this contract please oh ok we can we
come back to Kevin's question if we go
to violence Kevin always gives ask where
it goes sure yeah now we'll come back
together we have time oh sure okay um
went the database increased quite more
than then half if you have to keep track
of all the non-pathogenic polymorphisms
which can also modulate the effect of
pathogenic one so again I think that you
know we have to have we have to have
triage for the great question we have
their triage criteria in mind for what
makes a genotype informative and if the
effect of its constitutive of the
variances that contribute to it are
either purely additives so if in our
statistics they look like they they're
they're additive on their own so they
can be reported in effect separately
independently then we might sweep those
into a different category than might be
there might be an additive modifier that
might you know reduce the overall risk
of disease but not be crucially part of
that informative genotype and that's
sort of like knowing what you know what
else is in the bottle besides that
molecule we don't see them if we don't
incorporate you know we might know that
yes there's caffeine in the bottle not
strychnine you know it's not just the
elements but we know that there's
tapping in there and not strychnine we
also know that there's a little bit of
sugar in them inmate the the bottle and
it's and its effects are in somewhat
separate and independent of that of
those this stuff that makes up the
caffeine and i think that the additive
modifier question is a bit like that if
we have non-additive of variants that
are common but and but weekly it but we
can detect that they actually non
additively matter and yes i would argue
we shouldn't we
should actually incorporate those into
the data type but I don't think that
given we know today that that's a
particularly common scenario so I think
most of what we know is either fairly
clear non-additive interactions there's
there are a few examples that we've
started to talk about here or there is
sort of long tail to it to the best of
our understanding additive week effects
and those would just be reported
separately it's at all if we've been
deemed them clinically informative at
all in the line and just add one more
point of non-violence question in the
long run the database will be more than
double of size but that will be true
anyway even which with just variance
right because we're going to discover a
lot more so we know our database will
more than double in the long run I'm
just arguing that it is tractable today
for a lab with computer systems in place
to double their data set data size if
here's the we have time for just one
more question today pressure it is it
would seem that clinically classifying
genotypes has significantly significant
relevance for gene editing technologies
can you speak to this relationship yes
and I think that gets a point three here
on the last slide for a bench scientist
what you can do if you know if you know
crisper if you know how to use Chris
Burke at 9am right well I mean
parallelizing the functional assay of
genotypes that we find could help so
much given that there's only seven
billion people and you know maybe we
will have 10 billion if we if we
population grows you know modestly and
that's simply not enough for the
statistics involved to know whether
somebody to type straight o'clock matter
so the way we're going to have to do
that is by directly assays and so I'm
glad that point Scott Scott asked and I
see one more question by the way about
about trios so asking you know if we're
going to focus on genotypes shouldn't we
be always be sequencing parents in the
family where they're available not just
a thicket and I think that's a great
point Christopher making that sequencing
is getting cheap enough we can much more
sharply understand typically what's
going on in terms of the etiology of
much of a sick child by adding the trio
information now so even for the urgent
diagnostic use that matters and in the
long run for that
for more broadly documenting what
genotypes matter sequencing three times
you know three people and including two
unrelated is going to help us get there
much faster so thank you for that point
thank you I would once again like to
thank dr. Pearson for his presentation
to have any final comments for today so
on Kevin's question what most excites so
Kevin Kevin I can't see everything but I
think he's asked me what most excites me
or any of us here about President
Obama's precision medicine initiative
and you know this is hopefully we talked
here a bit about some of the brass tacks
that faces and getting beyond the sort
of word cloud type of precision medicine
p for personalized medicine whatever
what have we it's great to have focused
at the top and our government
understanding that this is a long-term
aim understate getting big genomic data
and ancillary data from us as the United
States population will help us drive
science and make a baby's gmail my
generation from now much more
informative than a typical healthy
adults gmail today I think that's the
key is that when I talk with people you
know many healthy adults that talk with
looking at their genome they came in
hoping for crystal ball and health there
is no such crystal ball today and then
there's this so what moment like I you
know what why isn't it more informative
that's the meadow lesson it's not more
informative yet for a long-term health
because we haven't looked at enough
people over time in the context of other
information you know and phenotype to
actually make sense of what a single
genome means today and to get there
we're going to have to do so over a
generation it's going to be a long haul
well thanks again today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August of 2016 you will receive
an email from lab roots alerting you in
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to Ford that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event and
please join us for the last presentation
of the day by dr. moronga from Africa
after dr. Pearson's webinar concludes
thanks again for joining us see you next
time bye